there's a fascinating new chart from the
new york times and the mit media lab and
this compares coveted cases per 100
people meaning per capita coveted to how
people voted in the 2020 presidential
election and the results are so simple
that it's almost surprising but then
once you think about it once you look at
it you realize actually it's not really
that surprising and the bottom line of
the findings are as follows
if there are lots of trump voters
there's lots of covid right now over the
last month if there's a medium amount of
trump voters there's a medium amount of
covet over the last month and if there
aren't that many trump uh voters there's
really not that much covid spreading
either so let's take a look at the image
and very very nicely put together so
what you're seeing here are five
separate lines which track new cases per
one hundred thousand
so
the blue line means there are under
twenty percent trump voters in the
county this is a county by county thing
if you're not watching i'm going to
describe this to you and then it goes
from the blue line all the way up to the
bright red line that means more than 80
percent of a county has trump voters now
remember that if you go back to the
beginning before we knew much about
covid
early covid hit the places with the big
airports that are directly connected to
asia and europe and those are mostly in
blue states so early on at the start of
the pandemic and you look to the left
side of the chart in april you saw that
it was blue counties with more covid
because we had this airport-based
initial spread you had new york city you
had boston new york airport over over
the water in jersey san francisco
eventually la et cetera
now after a year and a half of the
pandemic having vaccines understanding
guidelines you've essentially seen
that since roughly august or september
of 2020 it's been the red counties that
on a per capita basis are leading the
covid case rates the more red the county
the more they are leading in terms of
cases and that's not good
the lowest new case rates right now
are in the counties with fewer than 20
percent of the population less than 20
percent of the population fewer than 20
trump voters those are the places with
the least covet
followed by the places with 20 to 40
percent trump
and then the places with 40 to 60
percent trump voters have more coveted
and then the places with 60 to 80
percent trump have more covet and the
places over the last month with the
highest per capita coveted case rates
are the counties where more than 80
percent of the population voted for
donald trump and it's not by a small
margin if you look at those
20 or or or lower percent trump counties
they only have 25 new cases per 100 000
if you look at the 80 plus percent trump
counties they have 65 new cases per 100
000 in other words the big trump
counties
have about two and a half just shy of
three times the new case rate than do
the very democratic leading counties
it's truly incredible to see this
translate
perfectly into virus spread now we
expected this intuitively we expected
this
but the data shows it cleanly and
clearly now you might correctly say
this can't be good for winning elections
right like in other words if it's mostly
your voters who are getting sick
and overwhelmingly your voters that are
going to the hospital and overwhelmingly
your voters that are dying that probably
isn't good for winning elections right
and you would be completely correct
except republicans aren't actually
trying to win
by having more people who agree with
them go out and vote republicans for a
long time and recently and into the
future are trying to win by planning to
suppress the vote and making it harder
for people unlikely to vote for them to
actually be able to get a vote counted
not by winning people over on policy
ideas that being said let's go back to
the discussion that we had last week
last week we talked about how florida's
death toll now exceeds ron desantis
margin of victory in 2018. now it's not
relevant yet because that death toll
includes uh includes children who don't
vote
uh who weren't part of that margin of
victory it includes non-voter non-voting
adults as well
and it's a mix of republicans and
democrats but it is absolutely plausible
that over time the partisans split in
deaths if it continues to shift to where
it goes to be you know 55 percent of the
deaths are republicans 60 percent of the
deaths are republicans 70
eventually you could get a partisan gap
such that you have enough more
additional republicans dying of covid
that it starts to impact elections now
sadly we can't just look away
and say to each their own
let them go and kill themselves because
vaccinated people still can get sick not
everybody can get vaccinated vaccinated
people could end up in the hospital
vaccinated people could end up dying in
part
thanks to the increased spread caused by
the right-wing anti-vaccine people but
it's a very similar pattern to what we
saw with the spanish flu earlier urban
areas got hit harder we saw that with
covet as well
more because of airports it's unclear
about the effect of the population
density but there may be one
but by the end of the day by now what we
are seeing
is that it's the most conservative areas
the most trump voting areas many of
which are rural that are getting hit the
hardest and it's two things it's the
lower rate of vaccination and it's the
higher rate of ignoring all of the
guidelines that at this point we have a
pretty good understanding of in terms of
preventing covets so an unsurprising
chart
but
very informative in terms of it can feel
vague i don't know we can't see the
virus i'm just with friends this can't
be a bad thing or i didn't get a shot
but it it translates to real world data
and we see it very clearly there not a
factor here
uh our religious beliefs but the
republican governor of mississippi tate
reeves certainly seems to think that
that is a factor and i want to talk
about that a little bit next